[Music]
okay let's go um another speedrun game
10 plus zero sure let's play let's play
chess Lebanese solid 2400 so we're
playing a national master from Canada
played him in Blitz quite a number of
times he's a really good player let's
kick off with the Sicilian hopefully we
get a Mainline nidorf looks like we will
yes we're going to get a nidorf and a 3
A3 uh I'm familiar with this move I I
know that it exists I don't know much
about it other than that it is like a
third rate sideline why is essentially
making a waiting move to determine
Black's setup like E6 versus E5 before
determining where White's going to
position his dark squared bishop and his
light squared Bishop it's not a stupid
line one interesting approach that we
could take is we could say Okay A6 is a
very useful move A3 is not such a useful
move so let's kind of transition into a
dragon setup with the idea that if white
plays in the standard way with Bishop B3
and queen D2 and long Castle White is
going to have a potential weakness on A3
that we could use as Grist for our Queen
side attack technically this is this is
the queen side so don't get confused if
I refer to this as the queen side even
if white ends up castling to that side
the pawn on A3 could serve as a hook
later on in the game if we run our Bon
down the board so I almost feel like
this is an improved version of the
Dragon some people call this the dragod
dorf like a obviously a mixture of the
nidorf and the dragon so we're playing
the dragod dorf setup with Bishop G7
looks like our opponent yeah Bishop B3
okay so he's playing it with H3 which is
I think a pretty reasonable way to play
it we're just going to play probably all
of the standard Dragon moves there's I
think two different ways to play this
with black we can go B5 and and play
this uh in a more nid ory way or we can
play castles and Knight C6 and play this
in a more Dragon style I think both
approaches make sense I am a nidorf
player though so let's start things off
on the queen side with B5 this is also
the more flexible move I don't
necessarily want to commit my king to
the king side just yet I want to wait
for our opponent to sort of put his
cards on the table in the dragondor you
also see black playing this weird move
H5 sometimes don't be shocked if you see
me playing it uh because it prevents G4
and it also prevents Bishop H6 so one
viable response to Queen D2 is in fact
uh to play H5 and I'll show you an
example of a recent game I played where
I successfully implemented this idea G4
okay so our opponent beats us to the
punch but obviously I'm not terrified of
this move all right let's F kto Bishop
B7 obviously Bishop G2 and now we have
to decide how to proceed so what are the
candidate moves here Knight bd7 and
Knight C6 also a quick mental note uh to
watch out for E5 in certain positions uh
once the bishop is defended so Knight C6
probably runs into E5 Knight B to D7 if
white plays G5 we can park our Knight on
the side of the board Knight H5 or we
could castle and meet G5 with Knight F
D7 but then we're really abandoning our
King side and I'm kind of worried about
that so H here here here there is Bishop
F3 and it is kind of annoying okay this
is a critical moment let me think about
this we could also play H6 we could also
play E5 lots of options
here yeah maybe G4 should not have been
allowed okay I'm leaning toward castle
and kingside here I'm leaning to yeah
let's go kingside Castle which is a very
risky move but I didn't like this this
bishop F3 idea in response to Knight H5
so G5 unfortunately we're going to have
to drop our Knight back to D7 which is
why I was not putting the other Knight
on D7 so that we leave this Square
vacant and hopefully I can generate
enough queenside play to prevent our
opponent from checkmating us in the very
like conventional Sicilian manner yeah
this is going to be dicey but it's also
going to be interesting welcome to the
Sicilian so a lot of you folks are
calling for E5 but remember that E5 is
an extremely anti-position move
especially in combination with a faneto
because the bishop start to complain
like hey what about this diagonal and
you're creating a big hole on D5 now you
might say to that but isn't it very
standard in the nidorf to play E5 and
yes it is but in slightly different
circumstances and you rarely combine F
and ketoing the kingside bishop with the
move E5 that's just a A good rule of
thumb in the knar and when you do play
E5 as vice versa 79 points out it's
usually when you can follow up with a
quick D5 eradicating the weakness on
that square we need two okay back to the
game
okay can we go Knight bd7 here again
there's this G5 Bishop F3 nonsense
although in this version I'm much more
amable to going down that road yes I
actually think that with the insertion
of these two moves castles Queen E2 I am
much more willing to sacrifice the pawn
on
H5 and if you're like wait what do you
mean sack the pawn on H5 what I'm
talking about is after G5 Knight H5
white has this move Bishop F3 and we can
essentially leave our Knight on H5 we
also have a move that just opened up for
us but even if we leave the Knight on H5
and white takes twice that's a lot of
Tempe that white is burning to earn
himself only a pawn and we can use those
Tempe to really start massaging White's
Queen side Knight to B3 our opponent is
playing very sort of very very tame I
don't see a reason for us not to
continue our queenside campaign let's
get the Rook into the action with Rook
C8 and now those of you who play the
Sicilian regularly should be salivating
at the prospect of sacking The Exchange
on C3 this is as textbook as it gets and
in this position Rook takes C3 is flat
out a threat because after BC Knight
takes C4 White's position starts to
crumble it's possible that our opponent
is going to go King side he's going to
get scared of castling Queen side and go
the other way yeah obviously one of the
typical plans here is Knight E5 knight4
okay so he allows Rook take C3 is there
anything I'm missing am I overestimating
this exchange sack um in a Blitz game in
a 3 plus zero game I would play Rook C3
instantly and I don't see a single
reason why we can't go for this line
Knight takes C4 importantly we're not
sacrificing a queen we're not even
sacrificing a full exchange we're
sacrificing an exchange for a pawn and
we're very likely going to win a second
Pawn so technically we're actually going
to be up material if if we're able to
take on C3 but that's aot point the
point is that white is unable to Castle
first of all because Knight takes C3
comes with a fork and if white has to
give away the light squirt Bishop then
you should kind of intuitively
understand that that's going to grant us
monstrous compensation for the pawn just
monstrous compensation and this Knight
on D7 is just lying in waight that
Knight is going to jump into E5 there's
going to be all these light squares
across the board this seems
really sexy for black no no no this is
far from resign the game is going to
continue but with 5 minutes left it's
going to be very hard for our opponent
to hold this together okay he does take
now very important Bishop takes E3 is a
terrible move because white blocks with
the dark skirt bishop and then the queen
is going to defend the light skirt
Bishop so obviously we have to recapture
let's not get to cheeky and I'm assuming
he's going to Castle it's probably the
best that white can do no no this is
probably objectively clearly better for
black but far from winning okay F3
sending our Bishop back now again Bishop
takes E3 I think is very shortsighted
because after Bishop D2 We are forced
into the exchange of Bishops and I
really don't want to trade my fieno
Bishop I don't think it's worth the
price of this miserable Pawn on
C3 uh to accept a an unfavorable trait
so let's move this bishop where are we
going to move it probably to B7 or A8 I
don't think it really matters but it
seems to me that Bishop A8 is the safer
move Bishop B7 maybe in some situations
it would run into Knight A5 and also in
some remote situations keeping all three
pieces on the same rank can lead to some
Forks later down the line Bishop A8 has
no drawbacks yeah but Bishop D4 can be
successfully met in a variety of ways we
can go Knight E5 we can go E5 and D5
we're not just going to you know take it
literally and figuratively I'm assuming
he's going to Castle and I'm already
thinking about the followup now what are
some kind of relatively straightforward
improving moves that we can make what is
on the horizon for us well I'm thinking
about Knight E5 that's like the the
standard move the queen can come out to
C7 but we have to be very accurate
because if we give white a lot of time
White's going to play Bishop D4 maybe F4
and white is going to start
consolidating so we really have to keep
the foot on the gas pedal here both on
the board and on the clock I actually
think Bishop B7 was the better move to
leave the A8 Square open for the queen
so I'm actually kind of regretting not
going Bishop B7 yeah F5 is is also very
much a possibility man Knight E5 and
queen A8 would have been lovely oh I
should have seen that but okay not the
end of the world so Knight E5 Bishop D4
this is a very important moment let me
think in silence for a bit actually
we're going to to go with a more
flexible
approach we are going to play Queen up
to C7 yeah with a pretty straightforward
justification if white plays Bishop D4
now we're going to play E5 and I made an
important clarification earlier and I
was criticizing this move which is that
normally the only time that you combine
uh the fian ketto and the move E5 In the
Sicilian is when you can follow up with
the move D5 so rather than using the
center for my pieces I'm using it for my
Pawn
and the Bishops are taking a back seat
Ro but they're supporting this huge Pawn
Center that we have and you might say
but aren't the pawns blocking the
Bishops and I've talked about this at
some length the bishop and the pawn
should be thought of as one unit this is
like one team and the center is massive
it's taking away all of these squares
from White's minor pieces eventually
we're probably going to go D4 or E4 and
open things up again but for now this is
essentially an impervious Central Pawn
skeleton
and now we can safely start attacking
these Queen side weaknesses so let's go
Rook C8 of course we could also have
consider the move d4 immediately but I
don't see the rush we're simply
attacking and threatening to pick off
all of White's pawns Bishop H6 at this
point already taking and queen takes C3
is a very tempting option but we also
could drop the bishop back to h8 which
is a little bit awkward this is a hard
decision I'm actually not sure what the
more accurate continuation is I have a
feeling that it's Bishop h8 but Bishop
h8 just seems a little bit flimsy I
don't love the prospect of kind of just
leaving that Bishop on H6 because we're
going to have a weak back rank of course
we could also play Queen C3 right away
and go into a clearly better end game
also very very tempting I think a
Russian GM would play Queen takes C3 and
just say listen in the end game White
just simply collapsing yeah let's do it
Queen C3 let's play like a Russian
school boy and I know that a lot of
people watching who are newer to chess
are going to be pretty shocked at this
move like aren't you attacking aren't
you down in exchange but yes and yes but
first of all we now have two pawns for
the exchange second of all in in the end
game the Rooks are just terribly placed
there's no open files for the Rooks
meanwhile our minor pieces have amazing
prospects the Knight has C4 the pawns
will start moving forward and we no
longer have to worry about our King
safety so I'm not arguing that this is
the best option but I think it's the
most practical one okay so now D4 is the
order of the day do we have any better
moves we can go Knight B6 we can simply
take the queen because if D4 he's
probably going to take and go Rook to D3
and try to chase our Rook away from C3
takes in G5 is also very tempting yeah
I'm going to try to play Ultra
positionally here yeah let's go takes
and essentially white has only one
active idea white wants to play F4 and
if we push E4 then the B3 Knight is
going to have a very nice outpost on D4
I want to prevent that from happening
okay now that's a moot point because F4
is no longer a threat now we can proceed
with our our main idea which is either
to play Rook C3 or to play but see D4
allows F4 but Knight B6 on the other
hand
seems like a fantastic option although
even there F4 we probably should not
allow on the other hand G5 there's Rook
takes D5 white can try to give the give
it back yeah let's go Knight
B6 an experienced GM would play F4 here
with white automatically but it's a very
hard move for like a 2,000 to play
because that gives away another pawn and
we might not even take it it's it's not
a Panacea to play F4 doesn't doesn't
solve White's problems we can also just
go Knight okay Rook A1 this makes it
very easy for us because White's just
playing Super
passively and I think here we can stick
The Rook on C3 attacking this Pawn Rook
F2 okay D4 there is F4 this is a perfect
time to play prophylactically with G5
preventing F4 now F6 solidifying the
center we're just trying to methodically
deprive white of all counterplay there
is no rush h 4 we can just play H6 yeah
we could also take this Pawn but then
that allows F4 now we're giving white
the H file but white just doesn't have
the the means to get the Rooks to the H
file efficiently because everything's
going to be hanging now we're basically
ready to play D4 okay Knight C1 our
opponent is defending resiliently we can
grab this little guy over here we can go
D4 let's go D4 this is not going
anywhere now our Knight is the last
piece of the puzzle I think our Knight
has not achieved its full potential
where does the Knight belong well I'm
identifying this beautiful juicy Square
on E3 let's get it there of course I
could also go through C4 but there was a
specific reason that I'm going Knight C5
I don't want to allow white to get his
Knight over to E4 because that's going
to make the winning process more
difficult yeah Knight E3 is coming and
and White's position is just crumbling
okay so he tries one last desperation
sack actually AG great move this is what
white what you have to do but we're just
very cautiously going to protect I don't
want to give away this Pawn but I think
we can use some tactics to protect it I
think we actually have Knight F4 in this
position yes using some tactics we're
able to protect the pawn indirectly if
white takes it we go to
H6 and then the fork will be unstoppable
a little bit dicey yeah but King H6 not
King F6 and now we have the fork and
white can only take one piece at a time
white is not able to capture both pieces
at the same time okay G5 is just a
useless check we can go down we can go
up I really don't think it matters but I
always try to emphasize P activity let's
go
up now we take here and we have plenty
of Pawns remaining the main Pawn is the
D Pawn okay now let's try to be ultra
accurate should we just push D3 then
white plays F4
why allow any of that what's the Russian
school boy move it's just dropping the
Knight away to E4 and eliminating the
pawn we can also play D3 by the way if
we want to be fancy if you insist on
being fancy you can play D3 here if you
insist on being Ultra accurate you can
play D3 this is very pretty F takes C4
we check and go D2 but not recommended I
just want to end the game in style claim
that I sacrificed a piece
okay now it's very easy we can go D2 We
can go Rook C1 and D2 let's go D2 King
E2 Knight C3 okay here we can give check
now another check forcing the king onto
the defile and then we promote white
resigns okay that game I'm pumped about
I think that was a really high quality
game which opens up a lot of Concepts
that we can talk about thank you to uh
uh Sebastian that's his real name thank
you Sebastian for the excellent game
well played well defended 90% accuracy
good okay let's put this into chess
base yeah GG all right just a second
okay so there's a lot to to unpack in
this game and I'll try to emphasize only
the most important moments but first of
all this move A3 against the nidorf um I
saw it a couple years ago um it never
gained a lot of traction but it's been
played by a bunch of Magnus has played
it uh a couple of times in Rapid and
Blitz Games uh Hari Krishna played it
Nakamura a lot of GMS have played this
move and as I explained as I understand
it the idea of this move is that it's
essentially a waiting move um now as
I've explained before in the night ORF
broadly speaking black has two types of
setups one is predicated on the Move E6
this is the shenan structure the type of
setup that I usually play uh is to play
E5 now of course against Bishop G5 E5 is
a really bad move nobody plays it you
have to play E6 I'm mostly talking about
Bishop E3 Bishop B2 F3 A4 against a lot
of different continuations you choose
between E6 and E5 the way that I was
taught the Knight or I mostly play E5 so
if white commits the placement of the
dark squirt Bishop then E5 makes sense
but what white is trying to do is say
okay if you play E5 actually no White's
idea as Hikaru and uh others have played
it is to go Knight F5 very interesting
white is trying to go Knight F5 and why
is Knight F5 not a thing in this
position or it's not considered a good
move why is it a thing here let's try to
understand that so Knight F5 is the most
popular move Knight F3 Magnus is also
played and basically if black plays
Bishop E7 here then Magnus has played
the move Bishop G5 so this is the bottom
line white is not committing the
development of the dark squared Bishop
wanting to put it on G5 in one Fell
Swoop now why does it make sense to put
the bishop on G5 here who can explain
conceptually why what is the idea behind
Bishop G5 why is this Square uh the the
most positionally sound what are you
fighting for here yeah so this is like
the most basic positional idea the one
that everybody should be aware of which
is fighting for squares and there's a
textbook game that is often shown I've
shown it many many times as a basic
illustration of fighting for squares let
me quickly pull it up yeah so here we go
smithl versus rakovski you can find this
this game in a lot of different books
it's also from a nidor and you can see
that again black has this hole on D5 how
does white fight for this weakness well
first of all smithl trades the Bishops
but the second move is the famous one
yeah obviously Knight D5 is terrible
black just takes
so a lot of people start suggesting like
Rook D1 Queen D2 by the way both of
those moves blunder the E4 Pawn what did
Smith slof do yeah Smith slof played
Bishop to G5 you're trying to eliminate
the Knight it's exactly the same idea
and to stick this Knight onto D5 which
is exactly what happens Knight to D5 and
we've got an amazing Knight versus a
terrible Bishop there are some tactics
here Queen takes C2 uh you can start
with Rook F2 the queen has to remain on
the C file to avoid getting forked and
then you bring the other rook in you can
actually go B3 and finally Rook C1 and
on the next move the Knight is going to
jump into C7 with a fork okay so there's
a tactical component to this as well but
you can find this idea Bishop G5 in a
million different types of games um and
and not just in the Sicilian really any
opening where there's a weak Square it's
the idea of eliminating a piece
particularly the Knight that controls
that square um I lost a very instructive
game to gakamsky
he implemented a very similar
idea here it is just a slightly more
advanced illustration slightly more
advanced illustration kamsky and nitzki
in this position this is from a Lopez
but it's the same structure kamsky plays
Bishop G5 I kind of made a waiting move
and now Watch What Happens he goes Rook
D1 controlling the D5 Square now the
Knight comes to F5 now he takes the
Knight and he plays the move Bishop B3
and now he's got a vice like grip on
this very very weak square and black is
stuck with a backward Pawn on D6 and
look at what he does he goes Queen D3
three different pieces are controlling
the square and now the knight from F3
where does it belong who can tell me
very nice and very instructive maneuver
relatively simple but still well you can
get it to D5 but the way that he does it
is he goes Knight H2 and Knight G4 he
hits the bishop and now he goes Knight
E3
and now he puts the bishop on D5 and
he's completely dominating the game
positionally he won in another 15 moves
okay so I can give you a million
examples of this but you get the point
fighting for a square by eliminating its
Defender is the the concept at play here
so back to the game back to the game um
Bishop G5 here black typically plays
Bishop E6 for that reason protecting
that square we're following the game
Carlson versus nari from title Tuesday
actually
and in that game Magnus played Bishop F6
Bishop F6 Knight D5 but in this
situation because black has another
defender of this Square uh the engine
does not consider white to be better the
engine does not consider white to be
better okay just a second my computer
froze anyways that's one way of playing
this line the other way of playing this
line is to play Knight F5 and this is a
lot more tactical so does anybody know
against Bishop B2 E5 now F5 what is the
theory move what what do the books
recommend here can anybody tell me let's
see who knows there's a couple of
tempting moves but only one of them
works cleanly I just have to reopen
chess base here it's not Bishop takes F5
that's just a trade it's not Bishop
takes F5 now you might say ah Knight
takes E4 cool tactic removing the
defender but no white has the intermetzo
Knight takes G7 and this is not
appetizing instead you play D5
undermining the protector of the Knight
if white plays Bishop G5 you push D4 and
if white plays Knight C5 you win a piece
with Bishop takes F5 the pawn is simply
overloaded Knight F6 GF and you hit the
bishop Bishop F6 GF and the pawn is
overloaded white loses a
piece so this is not a recommended line
for white I'm curious what is the
difference why is this supposed to be a
better version for white let's check
with the engine
okay so it looks like D5 yes Bishop G5
D4 180 games Bishop takes F6 is the move
now black plays G takes F6 most of the
time and then white plays Knight to B1
wow white actually doesn't go to D5 at
all white goes to B1 but why is this
line not played in this version why
doesn't white Play Bishop takes F6 here
let's get to the bottom of this
hopefully people are understanding what
I'm asking we're comparing two different
lines one the bishop is on F1 the other
the bishop is on E2 and the pawn is on
A3 ah I think I got it I think I got it
in the bishop E2 variation if you go for
the same line if you go for the same
line then after G takes F6 Knight B1 the
engine gives an edge for black here with
the move Knight to C6 and apparently
black is slightly better in the A3
variation after E5 D5 Bishop G5 D4
Bishop takes F6 G takes F6 Knight B1 the
position is equal the position is equal
if black plays Knight to
C6 ah okay this is a very very subtle
point but the point is first of all the
pawn on A3 prevents a very po
potentially nasty check on B4 the second
subtlety is that this bishop can be
brought out to C4 or D3 in one go so for
example here there is the move Queen H5
and in the same position in the same
position in the other line there is no
move Queen H5 the bishop on E2 is
blocking the White Queen from accessing
the square that's actually the point
white is able to stick the queen on H5
and rather than bringing the light squ
Bishop out to
E2 um white is able to immediately bring
it to the much more solid Square D3 or
even to C4 that's the reason that this
version is slightly better and this this
is what it means to study an opening
deeply right these are the kinds of
questions that you ask if you're a title
player when you're trying to get to the
bottom of a variation you do a lot of
comparison like oh how could it be that
making the move A3 is better than
developing a piece that sounds illogical
until you delve deeply into the main
line and there's usually like a specific
move uh that can like that the
development move is blocking such as
Queen H5 in this case Okay anyway sorry
to
go so uh so deep into the E5 Theory but
basically um E5 is a move but white has
these several interesting options
against it I decided to play in a more
dragony Style with G6 the main move here
for white that Magnus has played is F3 I
see Sidler Nakamura Carlson aronian
Carlson Nakamura Magnus won that game
most GMS play F3 in this position not H3
now Bishop G7 typically white plays
Bishop B3 basically playing this like a
dragon now leavon played B5 which is
kind of the way that I played played it
as well Carlson aonian London classic
that was a classical game actually
Magnus played Queen D2 and guess what
aonian played he played H5 which is the
move that I had mentioned uh during the
game Magnus responded with A4 aronian
pushed B4 and Knight A2 by Magnus very
typical idea trying to create weaknesses
on the queen side Aron played A5 and now
C3 this is a very standard operation the
point is after B takes C3 the Knight
well Magnus throwing the move Bishop B5
check Bishop D7 and then he played
Knight takes C3 black has a long-term
weakness on A5 White's got an excellent
setup in the center and it's not
entirely clear what black should do um
because if black castles King side which
is what happened in the game now White
Castle King side as well White's King is
safe and black has a very hard time
completing the development of the queen
side the Knight on B8 is kind of
stranded because Bishop takes B5 is
going to be met with a takes B5 and
Black's got this big hole on C6 this is
a very very bad position okay so for
this reason B5 uh is probably not the
best way uh to respond probably black
should play actually the computer does
like B5 but it doesn't like the move H5
the computer prefers Bishop to B7 this
has also been played now long castle and
only now H5 again a lot of subtleties
here why are you waiting for white to
Castle to play H5 because this Carlson
idea with A4 makes a lot less sense when
the white King has already committed to
the queen side obviously now this is
very very speculative and weakening so
only now do you play H5 and there's a
lot of games one Grandmaster played H3
and this position black responds with
Knight B to D7 kind of like we did in
the game and the computer evaluates this
as equal it's just an interesting
double-edged position Bishop D3 you can
get the Knight to E5 The Rook to C8 and
you play this in like very very typical
uh dragon knor fashion and white is a
very hard time here uh getting things
moving on the king side because our King
is still in the center white doesn't
have this typical Bishop H6 move and
white can try the move G4 um but we're
just going to ignore we're just going to
ignore and play Rook C8 and G5 is never
that scary because it's actually going
to help this Knight get over to
C4 so this H5 idea is a very good
takeaway for people trying to learn more
advanced ideas in um in the nidorf and
In the Sicilian it's it's a very radical
looking move but it actually makes a lot
of sense and you might notice a
similarity between H5 here and H5 in
this position which is considered to be
uh the topical line nowadays it's
actually the move H5 15 years ago this
was crazy when topalov started playing
it now it's completely standard uh to
prevent G4 okay so H5 and the Sicilian a
lot more common than it appears back to
the game so our opponent played H3
rather than F3 we played Bishop G7
Bishop B3 B5 so that doesn't really
substantively change how we approach the
position and after G4 Bishop B7 you can
already see why H3 is worse than F3
because the move F3 it protects the E4
Pawn so it does two things at once it
prep prepares G4 and it protects E4 now
white has to waste another Tempo
defending this Pawn um that Tempo allows
us to continue our development with
castles and here a very important idea
if we had played Knight bd7 instead
who can remind me what didn't I like uh
about this move Knight BD D7 what didn't
I like about this move it was let's see
who was paying attention it was G5
Knight H5 and now what annoying move now
what annoying move Bishop F3 exactly
Bishop F3 and Bishop takes H5 is
essentially Unstoppable now what's
amazing is I had a very similar position
uh in a classical game that I played
over 10 years ago and in that game I
played a really interesting idea almost
identical position I played Knight F4
and then E5 sacking a pawn but getting
my knight to E5 actually this might have
been the same position let's take a look
at that game here it is let's see how
this this position was reached I
actually don't completely remember so it
was a nidorf I played the dragod ORF
against H3 of course here he doesn't
have the move A3 included but very very
similar I don't have the move B5
included but in a very similar position
I played this Knight F4 E5 idea and I
pretty quickly because I recaptured the
pawn I got my queen and then I played B5
and in this position let's flip the
board I played a really really nice move
who can spot it black to play and make
an attacking Crusher black to play
really nice move here Bishop E6 Knight
on Z got it very nice Bishop E6 Queen
takes G2 there is Checkmate on C4 and if
white plays B3 you go Rook C8 Bishop C I
mean there's Rook C3 mate but this isn't
even pretty mate this is why I love the
knarf my opponent was forced to give up
the light bishop and I won the game
pretty quickly so it's not like if you
allow this G5 Bishop F3 idea you lose
the game but I figured this was
unnecessary by playing Castle's King
side I give myself the option of
dropping the Knight back to back to D7
if that makes sense um okay so our
opponent played Queen E2 which I think
is a bad move I think white has to play
G5 and after Knight F D7 white has to
start attacking on the king side and I
figured the position is very very
double-edged H5 you can play for example
Knight C5 and get the Knight to C4 and
the other important thing for people to
understand is that just because the H
file opens up does not mean that it's
automatically check checkmate a lot of
people they look at this position they
get terrified because they think a queen
will imminently arrive on H7 but it's
actually very very difficult for white
to get a queen not just on H7 but to the
H file at all um you can try to do it
through G4 but if you just close your
eyes and start sacrificing all of your
pieces that's not going to work that's
not going to work congrats you got the
queen to H3 but all black needs to do is
play Rook E8 and suddenly you realize
that you're at a dead end because this
is not Checkmate this is not Checkmate
because the King has G7 and that's the
power of fen ketoing your Bishop even if
why gets a queen to H7 it's not always
decisive okay but in any case let me
just refresh really quickly in any case
white should have gone G5 Queen E2 is a
waste of time now Knight B D7 already
makes a lot of sense and here if white
plays G5 and Bishop H3 we have the move
Knight F4 straight away the Knight on D4
has lost its Defender and black just has
an amazing position so okay so Knight
B3 our opponent plays passively we go
Rook C8 um Rook D1 and Rook takes C3 is
completely automatic I think Rook D1
might be a decisive mistake the engine
gives short castles as the relatively
best here we can play Knight B6 and
Knight C4 minus over plus so black is a
great position here as well a funny
story about Rook takes C3 which is a
very very textbook sacrifice in uh most
Sicilians um in
2006 I attended a chess camp with
Gregory kaidanov who was uh GM who
hosted the US chess school and at the
end of the Camp he gave everybody a
homework assignment like a fun challenge
for the next edition of the camp next
year and my challenge was to sacrifice
an exchange positionally uh at some
point in the next year and that
opportunity came just about a year later
right before I uh flew off to Kentucky
for the next vers for the next edition
of the camp I played the following game
okay I played the following game against
the 1900 we reached this position and
here I played Rook C8 Rook A1 and I
decided let's go Rook takes C3 Exchange
sack what's interesting about this
particular version of The Exchange sack
is that white actually can play Queen
takes C3 white doesn't even have to ruin
his Pawn structure but even in this
version the minor pieces are so
incredibly strong that the sacrifice is
worth it everything is coming out Queen
D4 Bishop F6 and uh it's a worthwhile
sack our my opponent played BC and here
I played this bishop B4 Queen A8 idea
and I was able to win the game fairly
quickly
um yeah so anyways I could show you a
lot of uh thematic examples of this
exchange sack but I really don't think I
need to I think you kind of get the
point and hopefully the course of the
game showed you the power of this
exchange sack on C3 which can come in a
wide variety of ways it's not always
sound sometimes you don't get enough uh
for the exchange but in this case not
only do we get enough but we're just
completely winning because White's
position collapses any questions thus
far I know that was a lot any questions
thus far oh someone was asking why isn't
there an E5 tactic and by the way this
E5 tactic you should make a mental note
is very commonly missed by black in any
situation where the Bishops are staring
at each other uh even Magnus Carlson
once blunder this even Magnus Carlson
once blundered this as a
2300 um let's see if I can remember this
correctly yeah there was this game
Magnus played against the 2400 and in
this position he played B6 B takes E5 B
takes C5 bang bang bang Magnus blunders
a full piece
2003 obviously the idea is after EF both
Bishops are hanging so Magnus was forced
to give up a full piece um yeah so just
watch out for that but the prerequisite
for this tactic to work is that the G2
Bishop has to be protected if it's not
protected we can take the Rook but we
can also just simply take F6 and drop
the bishop back thank you shooter
Starcraft for the raid so here we have
nothing to worry about Knight takes
E4 Bishop takes C4 Bishop takes C4 I
could show you examples of when Rook
takes E3 is bad but I'd have to find
them uh so I'm not going to do that
right now this game is about when Rook
takes C3 is good okay so Bishop A8
castles and queen
C7 here I think I played very accurately
because a lot of people would go Knight
E5 actually think Knight E5 is a mistake
who can explain why if you're watching
on YouTube pause the video and try to
understand why this very natural move
gives up a share of Black's Advantage
it's not a blunder but it is a serious
mistake so some of you might say oh it's
because white plays F4 and chases the
Knight away but here the Knight just
jumps over to C4 the point is not that
white plays F4 immediately it's that
white has this very unpleasant move
Bishop D4 and I was discussing during
the game how you don't necessarily want
to trade the dark squ Bishops and here
it's very very hard to avoid because F4
is coming on the next move and there is
very little that black can do about it
whatever Queen C7 F4 and as a result of
the trade white is able to generate
counterplay in the long run against
Black's King and just the bishop on G7
is a huge asset in these positions now
you could say well what about G5 here
but G5 seriously weakens our King side
and white can start seeking counter play
with H4 so for that reason I made a
semi- waiting move with Queen C7 I
wanted to leave the E5 score vacant in
case white played Bishop D4 and he did
and now we push E5 followed by D5 with
just an incredible Pawn Center okay so
Queen D2 Rook C8 Bishop H6 and I decided
on Queen takes C3 um it's not the top
engine move the engine actually prefers
to take and then give a check on B6 and
capture on C3 with the The Rook for
example Rook F2 Rook takes C3
threatening several pawns white has to
waste the tempo on King G2 now we push
D4 and White's position is collapsing
the queen operating alone is unable to
generate any meaningful counterplay
against the king so this is totally
winning for black but I decided to play
in the more Russian school boy
method our opponent I think didn't
defend in the best possible way maybe
there were more resilient options but I
just wanted to highlight a couple of
important moment so first of all here uh
Rook C3 is very tempting and it was
possible D4 is also very tempting but
very very bad because white plays F4 and
starts undermining the center so notice
that I'm not rushing to push the pawn D4
isn't going anywhere Rook A1 we push we
play Rook C3 so instead of Knight C4
which kind of blocks off The Rook now we
push G5 to prevent F4 F6 solidifies the
pawn Center H6 I could take on H but I
didn't want to deal with the
complications then D4 opening up the
bishop and optimizing the Knight and
finally using a little bit of tactics
right this is the the part that a lot of
people struggle in Knight F4 very
important move Rook takes G5 check and
now not King F6 which would have
blundered the Knight but you go King H6
and white cannot stop the fork with
Knight H3 so it's a nice I think
combination of prophylaxis and very
active moves we cut off all of the
counterplay and that makes the winning
process a lot easier to attain and then
finally after all was said and done D3
is a nice little touch F takes C4 you
should know this idea Rook C1 check but
not D2 because King E2 stops the pawn
first you check on C1 then you play D2
and D1 Queen is Unstoppable okay just to
show a little bit of dominance and that
was that folks I hope you enjoyed the
game I think this was a really
instructive one it was a typical kind of
siil win you might ask like where were
our opponent's big mistakes I think
there were a couple I think H3 is
actually inaccurate then I think Queen
E2 is a very serious mistake it's a very
slow move that allows us to complete our
development and start setting up these
nasty ideas probably Knight B3 was also
not great and finally Rook D1 just walks
right into the sacrifice and now the
sacrifice is on steroids because white
also walks into the potential Fork so he
was forced to give up the light script
Bishop okay too much to process says
Rashid V well that's why this goes on
YouTube you can watch it again and you
can pause at your leisure thanks
everybody we're going to call it here
this is almost five hours I'm exhausted
but this is a really really fun stream
I'll play it by year thanks everybody
thanks for hanging out
[Music]
bye